Black Panther is a hugely important
Marvel character hugely important in the
history of comics and it felt like the
best way to introduce him was within
Captain America Civil War when there was
an opportunity in the Civil War
development process where we needed
another character he was the one and
only person on the list introducing
Black Panther was really exciting for us
and sort of fortified our beliefs that
he deserved his own standalone movie we
put together a cap and a crew among the
best we've ever assembled led by a
director Ryan Cooper Panther he kind of
exists in a gray area in addition to
being a soldier he has a more important
job which is a politician he's
constantly making these choices in the
fog of politics in the fog of war we
deal with royalty we deal with royal
families but unlike our other film it's
right here on earth you get to explore
different cultures in different aspects
of our world for black panther and the
world of Wakanda it's finding those
real-life touchstones that we think
gives the film and integrity that's
still making it something that you've
never seen before
[Music]
it's a flame defend you pain will change
when you call came they'll do never
father you know I rock what you like to
brother ain't no pressure how about me
and you make a movie in memory remember
lettuce faster got a lover way we put it
all together tap came come to got take
down for the one two got one thing see
the one so know how many my dreams will
come true hey everybody whole bunch of
black pants are dropping tonight so
hopefully this will help get you ready
this also kind of confirms a Captain
America Theory during the Black Panther
movie so I'll explain what's going on
there is going to be a trailer dropping
really soon so be sure to subscribe to
get that of course I'll do a video for
it but it's going to be a little bit
like Deadpool because this movie is
coming out in February next year so what
you'll see is just like when they were
marketing Deadpool these are sort of
dropping a whole bunch of stuff right at
the end of the year when you see Thor
drop in November that's when you'll see
them start pushing Black Panther
big-time the synopsis read Black Panther
follows T'Challa who after the death of
his father the king of Wakanda returns
home to the isolated technologically
advanced African nation to succeed to
the throne to take his rightful place as
king but when a powerful old enemy
reappears two challahs metal as king and
black panther is tested when he is drawn
into a formidable conflict that puts the
fate of Wakanda in the entire world at
risk faced with treachery in danger
the young king must rally his allies and
release the full power of black panther
to defeat his foes and secure the safety
of his people in their way of life
there's a couple big things that jump
out at you unleash the full power of
black panther so that implies that we've
only seen a taste of what he can do and
I think that reversed is a more mystical
side of his abilities
he's Black Panther king of the Dead and
king of Wakanda so it's sort of like an
avatar thing if you ever watch The
Legend of Korra or Last Airbender where
they have access to all the previous
avatars memories and abilities it's the
same thing with Black Panther except he
can actually summon their spirits and
talk to them star wars force ghost style
so we'll see how they deal with that
Black Panthers are more grounded
character than someone like
dr. strange but maybe we'll see some
really cool really weird stuff when they
talk about the powerful old enemy though
they're talking about ulysses klaw the
treacherous stuff they're talking about
as kill monger he's a big villain but
he's not the biggest villain clause sort
of like the worldwide arms dealer
the anti Tony Stark but I always say
keep your friends rich and your enemies
rich and wait to find out which is which
stock well
Tony Stark used to say that and they
you're one of his so he's the one that's
probably going to try and pull them into
worldwide conflict through whatever kind
of vibranium heist he's trying to pull
so if you've never read a Black Panther
comic before now is the time to start
summer is the perfect time to catch up
on that to Hani Coates is doing this
great run it's called Black Panther
nation under our feet you can start with
that you can do some of his origin
stories is a really hardcore Christopher
priest Marvel nights run that was when
Marvel was trying to butch up his comics
because sales weren't doing so good so
it took some of its less popular
characters at the time and created
Marvel Knights and just let them be
super hardcore that was joke Asada's
project and a lot of the tone of those
comics actually ended up informing
Marvel's Netflix stuff so if you really
like what's going on with Luke Cage and
all the Marvel Netflix series you had
this Marvel Knights Christopher priest
stuff to thank for that he's also
currently writing the Deathstroke
rebirth series at DC Comics right now
that's the kind of characters that he
writes so if you want hardcore Black
Panther that's your best pick the new
stuff is better to read if you want to
learn more about the complexities of
Wakanda because there's just so much
stuff that they haven't explored and
that's what they're pushing into in
Marvel phase 3 and phase 4 one of the
producers on the Black Panther movie was
hyping up phase four he said you're
going to see a lot more diversity in the
way they conceptualize their movies so
you see what Conda we've never seen that
before a brand new thing but they don't
want to stop doing characters like
Captain America or Black Widow so you
see them pop up in infinity war this is
the first day of filming for Black
Panther scenes during infinity war
Loki confirming that there will be some
Captain America stuff happening in the
Black Panther movie
so until they figure out how to get this
stuff out of my head I think going back
under is the best thing now I don't
think it's going to be anywhere near
Iron Man and spider-man homecoming he's
really like a main character Captain
America will probably be very very minor
at best and black panther same goes for
Black Widow I feel like they had really
great chemistry on-screen together back
during winter soldiers so they might be
pairing them together while they're not
getting their own solo movies
so wherever Captain America pops up I
wouldn't be surprised if Black Widow
pops up between now and infinity war but
if it wasn't clear when she had that
last interaction with Tony Stark
be careful they're coming for you you're
the one that should watch your back
Black Widow is definitely on the run
with Captain America because like Iron
Man says T'Challa told Ross what you did
they're coming to arrest you but when
you first meet him in Civil War he's
still the prince he's become the Black
Panther already the mantle has been
passed typically that doesn't happen
until someone becomes king they'll deal
with the coronation in the Black Panther
movie so you'll get the whole swath they
said it's going to be a non-traditional
origin story in the way the Doctor
Strange was a non-traditional
origin story but that was actually a
little more straight-up I think that
they were kind of afraid of the Doctor
Strange character because he's so weird
and they haven't done a lot of
straight-up magic so they pulled a
couple punches Black Panther has a
little more freedom to be different
because it's all there in the pitch
you're literally going to another
country in an isolationist territory
that you've never seen before so often
the distance you can see Tony Stark just
salivating wanting to get his hands on
some of that technology and some of that
vibranium because Wakanda is the most
advanced nation in the world there was a
Miss Marvel comic recently that did a
great job of explaining just how much
more advanced they are there Kamala Khan
has a friend at school who's this great
honors student but for his protection
he's sent to Wakanda to hide out and
because he's so smart he gets a
scholarship for one of their schools but
the first day of school he finds that
he's like five years behind even though
he's like a PhD level student in America
so you have to imagine that the kids in
Wakanda are working on particle physics
while most children are learning
their alphabet and that's everybody even
the people that train to be warriors
even the women that become part of the
Dorma logic they all go through that
education process so it was almost like
a nation full of geniuses but you don't
hear about it as much because they're so
isolationist they tried to address that
during civil war it just you know
because their vibranium is so precious
everybody wants that honey that's what
all the cloth stuff was about during
Avengers age of Ultron he had stolen a
bunch of vibranium but they caught him
and they raked him over the coals he
didn't have the mechanical hand like he
did in the comics but because Ultron cut
it off during the movie maybe he'll come
back with it maybe he'll have a
vibranium hand because even though it's
very precious there are other people
that are able to buy it on the black
market but it's heavily regulated and
they're able to track it all over
Wakanda so if you stole even just like
an ounce of it they would know well let
me know what you guys think about all
this and leave all your requests for
Black Panther bonus videos there'll be a
whole bunch of black panther dropping
later this year but what's going to
happen is I'll post that trailer video
later tonight there's a little bit of DC
TV that you guys have been asking about
so I'll try to get that stuff out as
fast as possible while you wait for
everything you can click here for all my
spider-man homecoming that I've been
posting and you can click here for all
my infinity war videos thank you so much
for watching what I thought I'll see you
guys tonight
you